what's up my name's samuel leeds welcome
back to winners on a wednesday i'm sat
here with darren and ella from delaware
estates who have absolutely crushed it
they became financially free they came
on winners on a wednesday two years ago
but since then they've done millions of
pounds worth of property deals and
literally even the house that we're sat
in right now is one of their projects
where they've made 115 000 pounds
tax-free profit and in this interview
they're going to be giving you all of
their top secrets so guys firstly
congratulations thank you thank you so
much you guys have been killing it over
the last couple of years how does it
feel to be just like literally making
hundreds and hundreds of thousands oh
it's amazing i just couldn't imagine my
life to be like this now like two years
ago it was so different and now we're
well we've just made 115 grand on this
house
and on the drive you've got a bentley a
range rover yeah what else yeah old
yeah yeah so what's the what's the
strongest reason because you guys work
so hard you've got a beautiful little
daughter sienna who's five years old
what's the reason i mean you've worked
ridiculously hard what is it that's kept
you going over the over the last few
years
i don't know just pure grit i think like
we've just bit got our heads down and
just got on with it and like we want
a nice life we want to move abroad you
are moving abroad yeah we are moving
abroad we're going to say so we're going
to go to majorca when are you moving
well as soon as this household goes
through because we're living in it at
the moment which will be two or three
months or three months
but does that mean that you're gonna be
retiring or definitely not wow i think i
want a bit of down time just to like
appreciate everything that we have over
the last couple of years
like what's the point if you can't you
know appreciate what you've done and you
know enjoy it you're saying that because
you're tired right now yeah i think i'm
a little bit two months into retirement
i can predict you're gonna be like right
next deal well i keep saying that's it
i'm gonna retire and yeah i just keep
saying then i'm gonna retire and go and
play golf and just get on the beach
no definitely not everyone said darren
that is not you that's
you know why do you teach and do this
and do that and it's like because when
when you've made a lot of money suddenly
it's not about the money it's about the
game yeah and it's about the fulfillment
and the satisfaction
you know so how many development deals
have you done in the last couple of
years
10 i think yeah
and they've literally made a lot of them
we're going to talk about some of the
challenges and some of this the ones
that haven't gone to plan but on average
how much profit would you say you make
every time you do a deal
average flip-wise brrs and stuff has got
to be what
50-100 i mean they're all pretty much
over 50 aren't they yeah i'd say in the
middle probably about 75
but the very first one was 25
oh right yeah that was yeah the first
year the second one colebrook was 60 or
80 80 odd i think
i don't know it feels like ages ago now
but that's like but that's like a
full-time salary yeah
on a deal and you've done 10 of them in
the last couple of years yeah um talk to
me about the blackpool deal because i
want people to know the struggle can be
real
yes you've had some projects you made
115 rounds off this one tax-free um but
you know talk to me about blackpool and
and what happened because that was a bit
of a disaster and i've been out to that
property i know it well it's a big old
project what happened didn't quite go to
plan uh you're right we've done 10
projects now they can't all go to plan
of course
i say it didn't go to plan we didn't
make 200k like we wanted to i think we
literally like ended up making a few
grand or breaking even even
but the point with that project is it
was mid-covered i think we got the keys
and like three days later they locked
the country down quite literally
uh we were on a fixed price fix them
with the builder
and then obviously had all the materials
go through the roof all of the builders
labor was like my nan's cat's got
covered i think i've got it i'm not
coming in yeah so it really did go go
wrong in that sense don't get me wrong
we got the project finished we exited
yeah
and you have to we spoke about this it's
like because if you don't if you just
say oh man i'm just gonna quit no you
can't and then it's also it gives you a
bad reputation yeah yeah i mean all of
our investors were paid back with their
interest so
yeah so our no money down deal is
possible
so why when you've made maybe a million
or whatever you made in property why
would you not use your own money why
would you keep borrowing money from
investors when you can afford to do it
yourself because i want the driveway
and i want horses
right yeah but
i'm just trying to understand and
obviously look i do the same thing but
i'm thinking a lot i get asked that
question a lot people say what why do
i'm worth 20 million why do i borrow
people's money to do deals the thing is
if you have lots of deals on the go at
the same time you're using other
people's to leverage that if something
does go wrong you want to be in a
position to be able to help that deal
out don't you so
why do a deal if you can't physically
pay that back yourself and you can do
three deals rather than one we've had
like three deals on the go at the same
time why do one deal when you can do ten
there you go yeah and it helps with cash
flow so say if you are using bridging or
something you need to fund a deal you
need to get someone paid you can you can
use that how much should you buy this
house for that we're in 165 165 how much
do you spend on the refurb one two five
one two three say 300 total yeah and you
sold it for how much 415. so you made
115 000 pounds profit after you pay your
investors yes after all your taxes
although you probably didn't have any
taxes yeah
we lived in the pace
we lived here so when you saw that you
paid nothing
we didn't
that's what i'm talking about why did
you not play why did you not play stampj
oh because it was uninhabitable right so
we
we actually had to bring this to the
solicitors because we weren't even aware
that you could claim for this example
they don't know
no they don't you have to know and you
have to fight your corner yeah yeah we
actually had to fight for it didn't we
we said no you need to do this yes and
it will go through and we've done it
several times now yeah
yeah why did you choose before you went
hard in property because i know you did
buy the blackpool one just before the
academy we did yeah it was a bit a
little bit hasty looking back yeah we
were keeping beans
tell me the story tell me the story
because i remember you came to the crash
course and then about two days later
you're like i found this deal and i
thought it'd be like a hmo or i was like
okay cool what is it and you're like
it's in blackpool okay interesting and
it's a huge block resident commercial
block and i was like whoa okay i went
down to see it i didn't even did a video
there and to be honest i do think the
deal was decent i don't think you did
bad i think that you found a good deal
it looked like it it was going to make
profit obviously covert came and things
changed
it was the builders that put the price
up i think that kind of screwed it was
it not yeah materials went through the
roof so the builders and i met the
builder and he was like yeah this is the
refurb this is the fixed price and then
he was like i can't commit to that
anymore i have the keys back but like
what was it that made you invest in
yourself before going hard in property
i think
well basically we've been doing a little
bit and flipping properties ourselves
just those two that i mentioned before
but
they
we knew how much we could do on our own
but there was so much other things out
there so we thought if we could do that
on our own what can we do with training
yeah right so
yeah that's essentially why we do and i
think as well when you're asking
investors to finance your deals number
one you're going to be in a community of
loads of investors which is great yeah
but number two it's much easier to ask
people to invest in you when you've
invested in you as well absolutely so if
you've got hey i
dropped some money in myself i'm trained
i've got accountants and sisters and
i've got support around me
then it makes you more investable
absolutely you know and of course you
can claim it all back and more credible
you know what you're talking about you
know what you're doing you can dig
yourself out of holes like blackpool and
come out on top yeah right imagine if we
couldn't have done all of that training
and had a particular team and like you
got texting
what do i do with this or whatever
whatever the question might be
and to dig ourselves out of that just
proves you need to invest in yourself
yeah otherwise
that would have gone under do you still
do rent to rent
yeah we still got rent around yeah yeah
still do that even though you can make a
hundred grand on one day are you still
not a good renter no i mean it's a cash
cow at the end of the day isn't it yeah
right it keeps everything going day to
day where are you where are your
entrepreneurs derby and bournemouth and
well we've got essays in weymouth as
well but they're not they're not renting
two rentals haven't we yeah yeah little
studio apartment in bournemouth that
does like 500 to a grand a month yeah i
mean
it's quite seasonal that one so in the
summer it can do like 1400 but then in
the winter it drops down a little bit so
over the year you know what about the
other one
derby is a four bedroom i want to say
party houses a lot of families go but
it's just a big cool house yeah pool
tables and hot tubs and dog doors and
stuff a bit like this house
well you thought about doing this as
service accommodation what made you
decide how do you how do you determine
whether to sell a house and make 100
bank or to refinance it keep it and rent
it how do you decide when to do which
just do it on a case-by-case basis
really yeah
every strategy yeah yeah
sorry it could have been a hmo
it was going to be we had hmo door
handles
just in case it was a service
accommodation prophecy as well
yeah then we actually had someone sign
up and want to rent it for 24 months
under a corporate letter wow
yeah
then we thought we just led it to a
family and just had to stand by to let
on asts
then we had the values come out
and tell us the figures and money talks
and we thought we take that money the
estate agents you're saying i'm all the
same what did they say they both said
415 yeah which we got six days later so
yeah it was a no-brainer really yeah you
can use the money to bring it abroad so
even had someone else offer us 420 and
said i missed it i was i think they were
well weren't there i missed the open day
with 420 buy it yeah so we couldn't even
go to a bidding war but
more couldn't yeah i think so yeah but
no we took the 415 we can now reinvest
that money into whatever we want to
invest in we've got investors that can
do stuff as well yeah we always like to
work with investors and look for more
investors because we can do more deals
and it makes sense because for
for them it makes sense absolutely
because like tell me about that joint
venture that you just did oh yeah so
we've got one in weymouth and it's a 50
50 jv deal and they've put in all the
money for the the purchase of the
property the refurb
and
they essentially get half a property uh
whether we flip it or we um we refinance
it and rent out as an essay we're not
quite sure what we're doing yet but um
yeah they get half a property and half
the profit for us doing all the legwork
yeah and the same thing is where did
that guy he won't mind me saying either
where did he have his money invested in
this house
no originally where did he have his
money invested what do you mean so he's
inve you know people having money oh oh
premium bonds premium bonds yeah all
right trying to say that he withdrew all
of it yeah yeah there's money and we
were like yeah that's the thing you're
doing them a favor because and also once
the project's finished they get all
their money back plus 50 of the profit
and when you're able to make serious
profits it doesn't compare to putting it
in a bond or honestly
he now says i can't believe i have money
this money in premium bonds for years as
well and over those years it was like
eight grand
yeah he made it straight away on this
one yeah yeah yeah yeah he actually
invested the money on this house as well
yeah and then you know and we've done
deals together you know yeah we've done
deals together which have always been
successful definitely yeah um what's
been what's been the hardest thing about
this whole business
i think you've just got to be a good
problem solver haven't you like there's
a lot of moving parts and some of it's
out of your control yeah so i think
that's why
it can be difficult but you just got a
bigger problem so go on what you're
saying yeah well it's actually from
layer cake
but the art of good business is being a
good middleman right and i think that's
the hardest thing to overcome but as
soon as you can get over that and you
can be a good middleman
i wasn't i was a middleman when you fell
out of your builder
we won't maybe won't talk about that how
has it been working with me over the
over the over the process of the academy
and everything it's been great seamless
easy and i know you won't mind me saying
but i've got your personal number like
even today the money that you're worth i
can still drop your whatsapp samuel
what's this who do you know for this i'm
stuck on that and you'll still answer me
so
thank you for that because you're so
humble that we can still do that and you
don't need to yeah but we now do that
for others as well yeah yeah yeah
starting out yeah and we've just got a
good friend of ours every simon that
we've got signed up for the academy wow
oh i met him yeah he's on the academy
and we had a guy a guy came around came
on windows on a wednesday just now on
when he's going to win is that the same
time
anyway i can't remember but my mom's
gone but he was on winners on a
wednesday yeah and at the end i said to
him whilst he had been like obviously it
was amazing and then i said how did you
hear about the academy and he said
darren and ella oh really you know and
you guys and i have to i have to shout
you guys out as well because not only
not only do you give back into the
community i know you guys offer so much
support to people
especially you um ella but i have to
shout you out darren because in 2019
when i was getting crucified by the
media
and there was people online yeah darren
was arguing with everybody online
looking everybody's straight yeah
i was getting a bit annoyed with the old
trolls wasn't i what happened
well i don't know why but i think i said
a few things back to people when and i
know you won't mind me saying but
samuel's a con man this training won't
work you're going to lose thousands of
pounds
and i'm there doing it but i'm earning
thousands of pounds not losing thousands
of pounds
and
what i was getting from the academy at
the time with my power team i just
couldn't sit sit on the side and just
ignore it so i'd actually like engage
with these trolls to the point where
they'd say
you know yeah but you're a paid actor
you haven't got anything and i'd just
like to send him a picture of a new car
and be like well i've just sold a house
and put another new car that i've wanted
since i was a kid yeah and to the point
where i just had to say
no that's absolute rubbish i'm living
proof that i've done it yeah but you
know what though at the time i feel like
that meant a lot to me because it's good
it's all right it's all about me saying
that hey guys know
i'm on the program this is how much
money i'm making i really appreciate
that and it shows
well that's it and to the point where we
recommend friends and family like go and
do this you're in a rut you keep asking
us like me and ella constantly how do i
do this what does brr stand for and we
just go
get on samuel's youtube channel wouldn't
we just just check it out and then sign
up to the academy and do it yeah i
appreciate it one of my coaching clients
actually today i
pushed her over to your youtube channel
to actually go and learn more
about
property and just get well you
is coming to my house
to to showcase a property that we've
just done successfully
and two you know two years ago
yeah i think it was just a dream really
the environment's really important so
ryan surrounding yourself and the you
know the good vibes and learning more
you can never do enough i've got a
confession to make go on
i'm a little bit jealous about this
house
because it's the perfect instagram house
it is very instagram it was so
derelict and now the way you've rendered
it the permitted development this didn't
exist before no permitted development
extension it's just like the before and
after pictures i hope you don't mind i'm
going to use the after because i'm going
to do some instagram posts i'm using
this house because go for it you know
it's absolutely incredible what would
you say to somebody who was wanting to
get into property um what what advice
would you give as people that have
you've now you know you've you've done
millions of pounds worth of deals we
just tied it up we went through all the
addresses we tied it up and it's in the
millions what advice would you say to
somebody that's sort of starting out
that's maybe just got that as a dream
what were the steps you would take get
off the fence really just start taking
some action yeah because that's what's
going to get you from a to b yeah
actually
yeah and i think what you said as well
about to get offense you've got to
commit haven't you yeah you've got to
say you know what i'm doing this
commitment for yourself get clear on
your goals and just go for it and and
know what you're doing which is why
education is so important uh and i'd
just like to touch on homes under the
hammer so everyone's watching they
haven't gone i want to be a property
developer
and you see on the program don't even
they say i'm a whatever they are
accountant whatever it may be and they
just buy this house and and they say
they made eight grand at the end of it
and it's taken them six months they
haven't made eight grand at the end of
it because that's going to be a loss but
they've not done any training they've
not got any power team behind them
they've not got any experience with the
first one although you need to take
action and go and do it you just still
need to know what you're doing yeah
that's why we put our money where our
mouth was at the time didn't we so right
let's get on the academy
let's get a deal that big blackpool deal
we weren't beating around the bush we
like action and get on and do it
and you'll learn a lot along the way
then with the people that you meet and
the connections that you make and your
parents
and just go down and do it and that
apartment is the penthouse you've got in
weymouth yeah you're doing that on
service accommodation yeah we are yeah
how much does that make
so that's currently making about two
thousand pounds a month it's incredible
flying just one property because it's
got like a hot tub on the roof terrace
private garden and all of that yeah it's
really really nice so it's flying isn't
it yeah that's beautiful so you've got
you've got your passive income coming in
facebook
and what's the what's the fascination
with cars darren like you every time i
look at you on on social media you've
got like a new supercar of some kind
yeah
and you buy them cash i do yeah i've not
got one car on finance now you used to
years back you used to finance a car and
but yeah now i've made the money through
property
uh and and bought the cars i'm just kind
of mad everyone's got their thing ella's
horse mad
and they're expensive as well
yeah they are yeah what about with
sienna are you gonna are you gonna um
because i always have this struggle with
kids
are you gonna give them like money or
are you gonna are you gonna teach them
or because you wanna spoil them like
what's your view on that she owns her
pocket money already
don't get me wrong she's my little girl
so i probably do spoil her yeah i'd say
and you say no no no or whatever but no
she has her in pocket money she's a
sweet guilder she's a sweet because
there's nothing worse than spoiled kids
is there i think like it's really
important that when you do have money
that they have to learn the value of it
yeah right and you have to teach those
lessons because it could be easy for her
to be like well mom and dad got loads of
properties i'm going to inherit them i
don't really need to do anything you've
always said haven't you she's not to
know about anything
an adult and older and proven herself
yeah she's not going to get to 18 and
then we're going to go there's 10
properties that we've had for years yeah
yeah i guess you have to teach her i
believe i believe with kids
to give them opportunity rather than
money so rather than just giving a big
handout
give them opportunity make them work for
it because tough times create strong
people don't know
we're not from money like we even said
on the first one
i don't want sienna to grow up and be
spoiled like you said we wanted to be
comfortable and if anything does go
wrong we know she's already saw it she'd
be fine now yeah
but we want her to get to the point
where she's got something like mine is
my car as well as her horses what's her
thing going to be you want her to have a
passion and work towards it and
appreciate her yeah so that's that's key
we're in a position that we can support
her as well so it's a nice place to be
in
you know i remember when two two years
ago in fact i think it was two years ago
exactly not quite to the day but give or
take a few days when you came on the
winners on a wednesday and i had to beg
you to come on the show
didn't you because you're like no we're
not ready yeah yeah looking back now
but no i said at the time i said well
we'll do we'll do an interview now
because you're financially free and
you've done some great stuff
but then we'll do another one in a year
or two and here we are so i just want to
say you know i really really appreciate
you guys and not just you know the fact
that you've done so well but also giving
back to the community agreeing to come
on the show a second time and share and
inspire i really appreciate it what's
the best way for people to get in touch
if they want to maybe talk about deals
or follow you on social media what's the
best way straight on the website yeah
i'll put a link in the description yeah
and then we've got instagram and
facebook amazing quite active on yeah
and i'd recommend you know going down to
the instagrams looking at the houses and
stuff because some of the before and
afters that you do are incredible yeah
so um amazing well guys appreciate it
you so much if you thank you enjoyed
that interview then go ahead and smash
the like button connect with dela
estates they're amazing people and
they're doing great things in property
uh also dear friends if you want to see
more videos like this there's a whole
playlist up here and
don't forget to subscribe over here
we'll see you
[Music]